hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled single cell virus sequencing of
influenza infections that trigger innate
immunity
this webinar is part of the microbiology
virtual
week event i am sabrina lemoos of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots now let's get started before
we begin
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble of seeing or hearing this
presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and thus offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner
of the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker dr jesse
bloom
associate professor at fred hutch cancer
research center
and investigator at howard hughes
medical institute
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top
of your screen dr bloom welcome you may
now begin your presentation
a pleasure to get to talk to you all
today and
uh as sabrina just mentioned uh be sure
to post any questions as they come up
and i'm
uh excited to address them at the end of
the talk so today i'm going to talk
about a project that involves
uh using long read pac bio sequencing to
determine
uh the actual full sequences of
influenza virions
that infect single cells and activate
innate immunity
so the work i'm going to describe today
was primarily performed by aleister
russell
who at the time was a postdoc in my lab
and is now an assistant professor at uc
san diego
so his way of background during viral
infection
heterogeneity occurs at many scales
so here's a picture of fort riley kansas
in 1918 this is during the 1918
influenza pandemic
which is the worst viral pandemic in
modern history
uh you know quite a bit worse even than
the current star's paround buyers ii
pandemic that we're having now in terms
of
uh the case fatality rate and here's
uh you know a picture of these these
rows of hospital beds where these young
soldiers who were stricken down by this
virus are
are laid out and about two to four
percent of these these younger
individuals who are getting the virus
were dying from it and so this is known
as this this terrible viral pandemic
but even in 1918 most people who are
infected by the virus did not die
so if you read the reports of doctors
who treated patients they'll say things
like this
the dual character of the illness seemed
obvious
after a week or more most patients
recovered benefitfully
but a distressing number suddenly
developed complications of devastating
severity
and this is really true of all viral
infections that we know about sort of
only a
usually a small fraction of people who
get infected end up getting really sick
or died
and so why is the outcome of infection
so variable
so it's possible to think of a number of
hypotheses
one is host genetics so there could be
something about the
genomes of different people that make
some of them more susceptible
to disease than others and that's
certainly a contributing factor but at
least in the case of influenza
we haven't yet identified segregating
genetic variation
in the human population that explains
most of the variation in disease
security
another one that's certainly important
is pre-existing immunity
so for instance one of the reasons the
1918 flu was so bad
or the current star's coronavirus 2
pandemic is so bad
is because uh most or no people
have pre-existing immunity disinfection
so their immune systems
aren't able to sort of control the
infection from the outside and vaccines
and and
uh you know antibodies from prior
infection can definitely ameliorate the
severity of disease
but we don't think this is the main
explanation in 1918 because
almost nobody had antibodies to this
virus but there was still this variation
in
god's sake and then another factor that
i'd just like to talk about is a third
possible cause
is stochastic variation in terms of what
happens early in infection
so what do i mean by that so we now know
uh thanks to nice work by j.p mccrone
and adam laurin
that influenza infections are initiated
by just a few
virions so we tend to think of
infections when we're at this stage
where there's massive number of virions
replicating in our
in our bodies but actually early on
there's just one or a few
in urians that found those infections
and ah sorry and so it might be
important
what happens in the first few infected
cells and that's going to be sort of the
underlying hypothesis of this talk
and so why might it be important well we
know that viral growth is a feed forward
process
so we have a cell it gets infected by a
virus and then the virus undergoes
exponential amplification in that cell
and makes a whole bunch of additional
viruses
we also know that the innate immune
response to viral infection is a feed
forward process
so you can have some cells one cell
might get infected
then another cell gets infected and if
that cell is able to detect that it's
been infected and activated innate
immune response
it can then signal the surrounding cells
to also help them
shut down the viral replication so we
sort of have these two feed-forward
processes
viral growth and innate immune response
and you can imagine that sort of
depending on which one gets a head start
that could influence the outcome of
infection unfortunately we don't really
know a lot about the variability in this
because most knowledge of these
processes come from bulk measurements
and the way these bulk measurements
typically are done is you have a big
dish of cells
and you put in a bunch of virions and
you then look
and see what happens and you're really
studying the average of this entire
process over all of these cells and so
by studying these average
or both processes we've built up the
following understanding of influenza
virus infection
at the cellular level there's an
influenza virion
and infects a cell once the virus gets
into the cell
it starts to transcribe viral mrna which
soon
becomes very abundant uh tens of
thousands of copies of viral mrnas in
the cell
those viral mrnas lead to the production
of viral proteins which make more of the
viral genomic rnas
and so there's even huger numbers of
these viral genomic rnas that are being
produced
and then the host cell can detect the
presence of these viral rnas
and activate innate immune response
which then signals back
to try to block viral infection
and so the original question we were
interested in is simply
are all of these processes happening in
the same cells
so is it the same cells where the virus
is making tons of viral material
that the cell is also activating the
native immune response and shutting this
down
or these differing outcomes and some
cells go down one path
and some cells go down another so as
you'll see
this initial question turned out to be a
little bit naive but we started off kind
of trying to pursue this this first
question
and so uh to do this we use single cell
transcriptomics
to examine infection in individual cells
so those experiments worked as follows
we take
a549 cells which is a human lung
epithelial cell line
and we infect them with virions at a low
multiplicity of infection
such that most cells are not infected at
all and the ones that are infected
are typically infected with just one
influenza
we then used a commercial single cell
transcriptomic platform the 10x chromium
to isolate single cells and droplets
after about six to ten hours
this device then takes these cells and
puts
a lego dt primer with a unique
nucleotide barcode sort of in each
droplet where there's a cell and then
that rna is reverse transcribed so in
the end when you pull this all together
you have these rnas from the infected
cells you have a barcode
for each rna that tells you which
droplet and therefore which cell it came
you can then just pool all of this
material and sequence it on aluminum
sequencer and the sequencing will tell
you two things
what is the barcode here so which cell
did that transcript come from
and then what is the sequence of the
three prime end of the transcript so
what gene
is it blocked and so that gives us data
that looks like this
so for each cell so in these experiments
we had on the order of 10 000
cells we've measured the number of
observations of each
cellular gene and then we've also
measured the number of observations of
each of the eight viral genes
so these are hypothetical data but for
instance cell one is expressing some of
the cellular
genes it's about 20 000 and the
transcriptome we're lighting against
and then the cell was not infected so
there's no viral transcription
cell 2 on the other hand was detect was
infected and made
tons and tons of viral transcripts so
there's large numbers of viral
transcripts
of each viral gene observed in that cell
so that's basically the data that we're
getting out
and i'm going to show you results that
come from analyzing this matrix
but we also did one other thing we
wanted to make sure that we were only
getting
single virions into the cells so we also
introduced
synonymous tags into our virions
so what we did is we took a couple of
positions in each gene
and we made nucleotide changes that did
not change the protein sequence
but change the nucleotide sequence and
then when we do the sequencing we can
tell if the viral transcripts come from
the green
tag virus or the orange tag virus
and so in the rare cases when a cell is
co-infected
it can be co-infected with two virions
in four ways two green
a green orange an orange green or two
oranges
and half of the time you can tell so
this allows us to
identify from our sequencing data half
of the co-infected cells
all right so now that i've explained how
the experiments work i'm now going to
take you through
what happens in single influenza
virus-infected cells
so again we performed these low moi
infections with sort of the purest
population of urines we could generate
so we
passage them a low multiplicity
infection generated from plasmids
uh and we got all all this high
dimensional data out in the cell gene
matrix
and a lot of the interesting information
can actually be represented
by just condensing this down to a simple
histogram
so now what i'm showing in this
histogram is just the cells that were
infected so just the cells that had
statistically more viral rna than
background
uh and then i'm showing what fraction of
the mrna in those cells came from
influenza virus
and so what i hope you can appreciate is
there's extreme variation
in how much viral mrna there are
infected cells
for some cells like these ones here half
or more of all of the mrna if 10 hours
post infection
comes from influenza virus and i
i think that was sort of really
remarkable that the virus is able to
make so much viral mrna
ah in some of these cells on the other
hand in most infected cells
there's only one or a couple of percent
of the mrnas from virus
so so one of the things that we wanted
to do is sort of quantify
that this distribution was very uneven
and in fact we got a reviewer for our
paper who said
uh you quantify that this is an uneven
distribution
so uh the best way i knew to quantify
things was the genie coefficient which
is what's normally used to measure
inequality and income distribution or
wealth distribution and so you'll
see this in the new york times business
section the gd coefficient is getting
larger
because bill gates has so much more
money than other people for instance
and so we can also calculate a gini
coefficient for this distribution
and in fact the distribution of viral
rna is even more
uneven in the distribution of income in
the u.s
so so for instance this cell this bill
gates cell
is making so much more viral rna than
some of these other cells which you
could imagine could be the graduate
students or someone on a less lucrative
profession
and so of course the question we wanted
to answer is why is this distribution so
uneven
so what's different about this infected
cell in this infected cell
which is allowing the virus to run
rampant in this cell
but make relatively little viral mrna in
that cell
and so a nice thing is we have this high
dimensional transcriptomic data
so we can examine the levels of all of
the cellular and viral transcripts in
each cell
to try to identify the cause
and so i'm going to take you through a
couple of hypotheses that what might
explain this inequality in viral
transcription across cells
so the first hypothesis might just be
that it has to do with the incoming
viral dose
so maybe this cell was infected with
lots of virions
and this cell was only infected with a
few variables
and as i told you we have these tags so
we can identify the co-infected cells
and we're able to use that to see that
this is not the major explanation
so here the cells only had a single
viral barcode
and here are the cells they're
relatively few co-infected cells because
we use the low moi
to have multiple viral barcodes and i
hope you can appreciate that the orange
distribution does not look
wildly different than the green
distribution so that's not the answer
a second hypothesis is that there could
be some variation
in cellular transcripts that explain the
heterogeneity and viral mrna
so this is what i would call the
pre-existing cellular state hypothesis
so the idea is that some of the cells
are in a state where the virus
can infect them sort of very well and
some of the cells are in a state it's
much more recalcitrant viral infection
so importantly we can't really answer
this question from our data because
we've just looked at a single
time point uh and perhaps this
pre-existing cellular state doesn't have
a transcriptional basis
or if it does have a transcriptional
basis it's no longer present
10 hours after infection but we can try
to get at the question by saying
are there cellular genes that are
expressed more in cells on the right so
cells with a lot of viral mrna
than cells that make very little viral
environment
and i guess what i would say is we
didn't identify anything particularly
striking
there are some correlations you can go
look in the paper here to see what they
are
but most of them seem to look like
things that to us seem
more like consequences rather than
causes
of the viral infection being so
productive so we don't really think that
the pre-existing cellular states
explaining most of variation we're
seeing or at least not
pre-existing cellular state that's
captured by the transcriptome ten hours
post-infection
so then i'm going to take you to the
third hypothesis which is that some
cells activate innate immunity and
therefore suppress
viral transcription and recall i was
telling you at the beginning how this is
what we thought would be the case we
thought some of the cells would turn on
this innate immune response
and maybe block the viruses ability to
infect those cells
however when we looked we discovered
that actually very few cells
turned on this type 1 interferon
antiviral response
in fact only one cell expressed any
detectable level of type 1 or type 3
interferon it's a cell right here
so you can see a couple things even
though the cell's interferon positive it
still has a lot of viral mrna
so the underlying hypothesis i just
presented can't be true
and this cell has a lot of interference
this is not just a single cell rna-seq
dropout issue
actually very few cells are interferon
positive and it turns out this fact is
known from
other studies as well that very few
cells become interferon positive
after primary influenza infection prior
to paracrine
so at the beginning i was telling you
how we had one question which is
why do these infections vary so much in
viral burden
and then i'm trying to answer that
question and looking at the interferon
response we came up with another
question which is
why do only a few infections activate
innate immunity
at all so now the next part of the talk
i want to actually answer some of these
questions in addition to disposing
so first i'd like to point out something
really important
i said that we infected these cells with
sort of a wild type
or pure stock of influenza virus and i
drew this by all of these identical
influenza virions going into these cells
but in fact for uh really all viruses
especially for influenza viruses there's
no such thing as a pure stock of virus
all viral stocks contain mutations
because the virus
is very error-prone in the replicates so
in fact we're infecting ourselves with
some heterogeneous mix of viruses
some of which will have specific
mutations
and so you can then imagine maybe
mutations in the virions
actually explain the variation across
cells
so this is a technically challenging
question to answer and i want to explain
why
the single cell rna-seq as i described
you
is really designed to count mrnas so it
just sequences their three-prime end to
see what is the mrna
and it gives you this matrix which
counts up how many observations of each
mrna you see in each cell
importantly standard single cell
transcriptomics doesn't
sequence the mrnas and there's two
reasons for that one is just technical
with short read illumina sequencing it's
easier to just get the three prime end
of the transcript from the full length
of the transcript
but the other reason is really
conceptual which is that people haven't
in general
tried that hard to do single cell
transcriptomics that gives you the full
sequence of mrnas
and the reason for that is for the most
part these approaches are being used
to study developmental processes
and if you're interested in
developmental processes for instance the
difference between
a brain cell and a liver cell is
not that they have different mutations
in their mrnas or their genomes it's
really that they're expressing different
mrnas
so if you're studying developmental
biology which most people using single
cell mrnac
are doing you really want this gene
expression information
you don't want to spend a bunch of time
trying to identify mutations in the
genes
however that explanation as i just told
you does not apply to viral infection
so we needed to come up with a way to
augment this
information with also knowing the
complete sequences and so all the
mutations present
in the viral genes so what we
then set out to do is combine single
cell transcriptomics
with single cell virus sequencing
so how did we do that
we started with the same process as for
the single cell transcriptomics
so the cells were isolated in droplets
and all the rnas were reversed
transcribed adding these cell barcodes
then once we had this pool of material
we did two things we took some fraction
of it and we just did the standard
illumina sequencing
to generate that big count matrix
but for some of the rest of the material
we took it and we enriched in the
transcripts that encoded viral genes
and then we performed full length pac
bio sequencing on these
using highly accurate circular consensus
sequences
so now for the viral transcripts we have
the full sequences of the viral mrnas
and because we sequence this barcode
we can tell which cell they came from
ah so importantly this now gives us the
full sequences of the viral mrnas and
the single cells in addition to the
transcriptomic information
and since essentially the entire
influenza genome is transcribed into
viral mrna
this is essentially giving us the entire
viral genome with just a few small
exceptions
so basically the key point is now for
each infected cell we're both counting
all of the transcripts cellular and
viral
and we're sequencing the infecting area
and then before i show you with those
data i'm just going to go through the
full experimental design
so we did a couple of additional things
i told you how in our first experiment
there were a lot of infected cells
and very few of them made interferon and
since we wanted to study induction of
the innate immune response by these
viral mutations
we engineered our cells so that when
they express
interferon so they turn on the
interferon promoter
they then also express a fluorescent
sortable marker
and then that allows us to enrich in
these interferon positive cells
so now we can get them up to a higher
fraction of the population
so now we basically do the following we
infected the cells at low moi
at 12 hours we enriched interferon
positive cells to 20 percent of the
total population
as a control we added some uninfected
canine cells
which we discovered as a useful control
to sort of see how much viral rna is
just
leaking out of cells and contaminating
the transcriptomes of other cells
and then we perform the single cell
transcriptomics and virus sequencing
so what do those results look like so
first if you just look at these
uninfected
canine cells which we added as a control
to the experiment
as you can expect none of the canine
cells had an appreciable amount of viral
rna
and we use the amount of background
viral mrna observed in these canine
cells which is just due to ambient rna
contamination
it's sort of a way to call which are the
infected cells
so then when we look at the human cells
most of them
1200 of about 1500 are uninfected
which is as expected because we
infected them in a low multiplicity
infection so that most should be
unaffected
but you can see that there's in this
blue histogram which kind of stretches
out along the x-axis
if we just zoom in on that blue part we
can see
that among the cells that are infected
we again
kind of get this genie coefficient
distribution where some of the cells
are making more than half of their mrna
from virus but most of the infected
cells have only a few percent of their
mrna
we can then look to see how many of the
cells are making interferon
so in this experiment as i described
we've now enriched for interferon
positive cells
so among the cells that are infected
about 20 of them are making interferons
so here's the cells with very little
interferon
and then here are cells that have up to
one percent of their transcriptome
interferon importantly that's among the
infected cells
among the cells that are not infected
essentially none of them make interferon
and this is as expected
in order to activate an interferon
response a cell has to directly detect
that it's been infected
using something like a radii or some
pattern recognition receptor
uh we can also look at the level of
interferon stimulated genes
these are things like mxa and
importantly
although interferon itself is only made
in direct response to infection
interferon stimulated genes can also be
made through paracrine signaling where
these cells secrete interferon to other
cells
and so as expected you see that many of
the infected cells
are making interferon stimulated genes
and also some of the uninfected cells
are
because they've received this paracrine
signaling in their infected
so this is all showing that these
infections are proceeding about as we
expected
some cells are making a lot of viral
mrna some are making very little
some are activating an interferon
response some aren't
and so now we want to go to this
question of how does the genome of the
virion
so the presence or absence of mutations
in the virion
affect this heterogeneity
and so now to do that we can use this
path bio
single cell virus sequencing that i've
described
so i'm going to orient you into how i'm
going to display this data
so here's just a single cell from our
experiment which i'm going to have
conveniently labeled
cell one so i'm condensing all the
transcriptome information into two
numbers
how much of the transcriptome is from
virus
flu and how much of it is from
interferon so this cell is making tons
of viral mrna
65 of all of its transcripts are from
virus but it's making no enterprise
so it failed to activate an innate
immune response
and then here i'm showing the consensus
sequence of the virion that infected
that cell
so you can see that this cell is
expressing wild type copies
of all of the eight of the viral genes
now let's look at another cell so this
is cell 72
it's also expressing unmutated copies of
all eight viral genes
it's also not making any interferon and
it's making somewhat less spiral rna
was still a fair amount 29 so this is
showing us that whatever the difference
between these two cells are it doesn't
have to do with moral mutations and
there clearly are some other factors
probably pre-existing cellular state
that affect exactly how many transcripts
are made
now i'm going to show you another cell
so this is cell 134
this cell was infected but it's making
relatively little viral rna
and we can see that the virion that
infected this cell had two mutations
one in pb2 and one in np
and for those of you who know about
influenza you know that np
and pb2 are both part of the viral
polymerase complex
so it makes sense that viruses with
mutations and it's their polymerase
complex
will not be able to transcribe as much
viral
now here's a cell that's making a ton of
interferon it's making a lot of viral
rna
but it's also making a lot of
interference and we can see that when we
look in this cell it has
two synonymous mutations but more
importantly we think
it's totally failing to express the ns
gene
which is a gene that is known to be
influenza viruses
main interferon antennas so this makes
sense again this virus has this genetic
defect
which prevents it from shutting down the
interferon response and so the cell
activates in the nerve
spots we also saw viruses that have
mutations in the ns gene that activated
an interferon response
and we also found viruses that had
internal deletions
or point mutations in the viral
polymerase
that often activated nerve
so so far i've told you all of these
examples where by looking at the viral
sequence we can explain
what happened or some of what happened
in the cell and that's often the case
just to make clear that it's not always
the case
uh there are some cells like this one
where the virion
is failing to express ns into ground
antagonist
and the cell still fails to activate an
inner ground response
and there are also occasionally cells
like this one that are infected by a
fully wild type baryon
but still manage to activate throughout
the response so as these last two
examples show there clearly is some
stochasticity that can't be explained by
viral mutations
but a large amount of what we see sort
of falls into the first category
and i'm showing a lot of this by
anecdote because we're sort of in the
space between having enough numbers for
anecdotes and statistics but i'll get on
to some more statistical conclusions in
a minute
and one thing that's really important is
we look at this data from all of the
infected cells which we're able to do
single cell virus sequencing
you see just how prevalent these viral
mutations are
we had 150 infected cells for which we
could sequence the infecting baryon
and even though we went to great pains
to grow a very pure stock of
virus only 49 of these cells were
actually infected by varions that were
expressing wildfire copies of all of
participants
so now i want to ask do viral mutations
contribute to heterogeneity and
infection
and so first i'm going to go back and
i'm going to show uh
how some of the heterogeneity and just
how much viral mrna
is present in the cell is explained by
viral mutations
so here are the cells that are infected
by fully wild type variants with no
mutations
and you can see there's still a pretty
decent spread in how much viral mrna
they're making
but it's relatively uh more peaked
than the distribution uh among the cells
that are infected by viruses that have
mutations or are missing genes and you
can see that this is a much
wider distribution it has a much higher
genie index
so overall this is showing that uh
viral genetic variation is a significant
contributor to the heterogeneity
and viral burden in individual cells
so are these viral mutations also
contributing to the induction of
interferon
so here are the cells that were infected
by fully wild type virions you can see
that most of them are making no
interferon
a couple are making a tiny amount of
interferon and just one
is making sort of an appreciable amount
of interferon
in contrast here are the cells that were
infected by incomplete or mutated
variants
although you can see that most of them
are still again not making interferon
there are many more that are making
interferon including some that are
making a lot of interferon
so this also suggests that mutations in
the virions contribute
to interferon induction and to validate
this further
we've looked at the most common types of
viral defects in interferon positive
cells
the most common types of defects were as
follows there were some interferon
positive cells that were infected by
viruses
that failed to express the ns gene which
is the interferon antagonist
there were some that had mutations in
the ns gene
there were some that were infected by
varions that had large internal
deletions in the polymerase
these were typically co-infected cells
so something would complement the
deletion
and representing the co-infected cells
with a darker blue
then there were some that had point
mutations in the polymerase
and so for each of these categories of
defects we validated that some of the
mutations we found
increased nuclear induction so this
plot right here is just showing uh
the number the amount of interferon
induction
from wild type flu varions urines that
have mutations in the ns segment
ah which we think mimics loss of the ns
segment or variants that have point
mutations in the ns segment
and then variance with some of these
mutations in the polymerase and i hope
you can appreciate that many of these
mutations all the ones shown here in
orange
are inducing a lot more interferon in
the wild
and so we next wanted to get at the
mechanistic basis of this so
it's well known that the ns gene is
flu's interfering antagonist so it's not
that surprising
that absence of ns or point mutations in
ns would be
interferon induction but we weren't sure
why
point mutations in the polymerase would
increase in their current induction
and actually right around this time
something really fortuitous happened at
the
american society fibrology i met aj
talbelfias
and he uh studies the polymerase complex
of influenza
and he'd recently uh discovered that
mutations to the viral polymerase can
increase the production of
short mini viral rnas which are
especially good
antagonists for innate immune receptors
such as radii
so we then look to see did any of the
mutations that we found
in our neuron inducing cells in the
polymerase
which map to positions like here and
here make the virus
more likely to make these short
fragments which could induce interferon
and so here is a plot showing that
if you take the interferon inducing
mutant
and you look to see how much
uh sorry let me uh
you look to see how much full length
viral genomic rna it makes you can see
that the wild type
is making a decent amount of viral mrna
and full-length viral genomic rna
whereas this mutant is making quite a
bit less viral genomic rna
this is on a full length template
however if you look on a short template
you can see that the wild type and the
mutant have similar activities
this is showing that these mutants are
making the polymerase less recessive
which means it's probably making more
short products which can then activate
the anatomy response
so we think that some of these
polymerase mutations we discovered are
generating
aberrant short rnas that bind to innate
immune sensors like redox
and i think this is just a nice
illustration how this unbiased approach
can find new ways that the virus
activates
so i'd kind of like to wrap up with the
key conclusions from my talk
so first of all viral infection is
heterogeneous
on many different scales
so i described you how during viral
pandemics like the one that we're
experiencing now
the 1918 influenza virus uh you know
many people get really sick
unfortunately
many people die but the vast majority of
people still recover and are just fine
and there could be a lot of reasons for
this heterogeneitis
uh severity of disease including the
difference in human genetics difference
in the existing immunity etc
but i showed you that uh actually
infection even at the level of single
cells
is highly heterogeneous just like it is
in people and i sort of suggested how
these
heterogeneity these two scales could be
connected
so perhaps there's some connection
between the variability in single cells
and the variability
at sort of the macroscopic scale but i'd
like to sort of elaborate a little bit
more
this is pure speculation but i'd like to
elaborate a little more because i think
it's very important to think about
how they could be connected so let's say
there's someone who gets infected and
they get really sick
maybe that means that they were infected
with sort of unmutated virions
pronouns without any defects that manage
to be productive
in the first cells that they encounter
and so these virions really took off in
their infection
now let's think of someone else who
maybe thinks they had good genetics or
were smart enough to get the flu vaccine
or something like that
but maybe what really happened is they
were just actually infected with baryons
that either had mutations
or just hit cells where the infection
wasn't productive
and so that infection simply didn't take
very well in the first few cells
that gave the immune system more of an
opportunity to get ramped up
and that's part of the reason that
infection wasn't just severe
and then we can also think of people who
maybe didn't get infected at all and
maybe they think it's because they have
really good hygiene or
really good at avoiding sick people
which certainly could be true
uh but uh
it's also possible that they were
infected with virions
that were defective and they didn't even
know that they got sick so it was sort
of in a board of infection but maybe
that was enough to prime their adaptive
immune system
so they were later and exposed to sort
of viruses without these defects
maybe didn't become a or didn't become
sick at all
so i want to emphasize that last part is
pure speculation but i do think it's
really important to think about how
heterogeneity the single cell level
in early infection might manifest itself
at larger scales
ah so thanks and i'd like to end in
particular by thanking the people who
contributed to this work
so again alastair rebel who now
assistant professor at uc san diego led
this study
we also got a lot of great help from our
collaborator paul trapnell
the university of washington and i
mentioned during the talk the
contributions by a.j
and then finally i'd like to thank my
uh funding sources uh and my
institutions particularly the fred hutch
uw genome sciences and howard hughes uh
medical institute so uh
with that i'd be happy to uh answer any
questions
thank you dr bloom for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have questions you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located to the far
left of your screen let's get started
our first question is what are the
advantages of using pac bio sequencing
over
oxford nano sorry nano pore sequencing
yeah so as i described in order to get
the single cell virus sequences we need
the long read sequencing technique to
get the the full sequence so you can't
use something like luminous sequencing
which is short v
so there are two uh long read
technologies at least i'm familiar with
pac bios circular consensus sequence and
oxford nanopore
sequencing and so the pac bios circular
consensus sequencing was super accurate
which made it extremely suited for
our purposes uh we got really high
accurate circular consensus sequences uh
particularly at the time we were doing
this i don't think they were comparable
high accuracy circular consensus
sequences approaches described for
oxford manafort
some are now being described we haven't
tested those out ourselves so it's
possible that you could do something
similar now with manafort sequencing
but we've just gotten such good results
with biosequencing that we're just
sticking with that
thank you the next question i have
coming in is the induction of type
i ifn in affected cells dependent on
virus subtype
avian or human origin on a single cell
level
yeah so that's a really great question
uh so the question
is essentially as i read it uh i mean
you could also ask about what happens in
cells of different species but the
the question as i read it is sort of uh
depending on whether you have
a human flu virus or an avian flu virus
would induce a interferon
in these cells differently we haven't
uh directly
done all the experiments uh to answer
that question
but i think the answer would be yes so
everything i was describing to you
in the work right there was with the wsn
virus which is a lab adapted strain of
influenza
there have been a number of other
studies uh
including a nice one with aj tavalthius
uh
by aj tobeltius looking at many viral
rnas and various other things
that suggest that avian adapted viruses
might
induce more interferon in human cells
than human adapted viruses and certainly
this would make sense from a
evolutionary or teleological perspective
you would expect that a virus
that is really well adapted to humans
might get very good
at evading the innate immune response in
human cells
and maybe a viruses coming from a bird
or some other species
might not be as good at doing all the
intricate
things it has to do to evade an innate
immune response in human cells but i
agree it would be
fascinating to look at this at the
single cell level
uh and we haven't done that yet but i
think that's a really great question and
i think something that would be
really valuable to do and that we and
i'm sure others are working on is really
sort of
compare uh the sort of dynamics of these
sorts of processes
uh across both different cell types and
horses isolated from different species
and there is uh it doesn't do it doesn't
exactly get to this question but there's
a nice recent paper
by anis lowen's group uh i'm
blanking right now on the first author
it's nate
that's his first name but i can't
remember his last name that that sort of
gets at this question with some single
cell studies and does show not
not particularly with respect to
interferon induction but with respect to
other aspects of viral replication some
evidence that
avian adapted viruses can be worse
sort of it undergoing single cell
replication
in human cells band can be adapted
viruses
so that's the thing
um the next question i have could this
approach be
applied to other viruses
uh yes i think it could uh
and certainly single cell
transcriptomics has now been applied to
some other viruses
i'm not aware of single cell virus
sequencing that's been applied
in this way to other viruses there are
some quasi similar things that have been
done in hiv
uh the key thing for the exact approach
that we were taking
is the virus has to produce
polyadenylated transcripts
because we were just using the standard
10x chromium three prime capture which
requires a
poly a tail for those illegal dt primers
to work ah
so for something like a flavi virus with
doesn't polyadenylate
its mrnas the exact approach that we use
wouldn't work
uh however there has been work included
by
steve quake and fabio zumini uh that can
kind of overcome some of these problems
using slightly
sequencing technologies that the if the
viral mrnas are not polyadenylated
another issue for the single cell virus
sequencing although things like back
biosequencing are great
there is a limit to how long you can do
a good circular consensus sequencing
both just a read length limit
and uh and sort of a
limit on how long something you can
reverse transcribe is
so something like a coronavirus which
has a 30kb viral genome
it's pretty hard to imagine capturing
all of that in sort of a single-pack
bioread you might have to
get around that problem somehow but i do
think this sort of
these basic questions and a lot of
aspects of these approaches
could be applied to other viruses and i
think that's a very promising thing
great the next question um is the cell
cycle stage at the time of infection
playing a role for the
viral excuse me from my pronunciation um
proliferation
yeah yeah that's that's a really good
question uh so
so sort of as i was mentioning we were
interested and i would consider cell
cycle sort of an example of
a pre-existing cellular state and you
can imagine that
cells are going to be at different
stages in the cell cycle uh there are
things you can do in these experiments
to synchronize the cells
at least if mom's sort of similar
cellular state importantly we could not
do that so the cells are going to be the
distribution of cellular
cycle stages and you can imagine that uh
that could play how well the viral
infection took off
because of the particular way we did
these experiments we're only sampling
the transcriptome
10 hours later so we have to sort of try
to use the transcript on the 10 hours
after the viruses run wild in the cell
to figure out what the cell state was at
the time of infection
this is sort of an imperfect process
we did do it we didn't find like really
strong associations with cell cycle
expression g cell cycle gene expression
and and
proliferation but as i said it's the way
we were looking at it
might not work because we're looking 10
hours later after viral infection
so the the key cell cycle genes could be
at different transcription levels and
so i think this is a really really good
question certainly in the context of
sort of certain other systems it's been
shown that
cell cycle stage at time of infection
could play a pretty important role
and i think a nice experiment would be
which we just haven't done would be to
synchronize the cells
and then do similar experiments and see
if that gives sort of
less variability in how well the virus
appropriates so i think that's
a good question sort of points to a
large area
that we haven't explored that could be
explored
got it we have time for a few more
questions um someone from the audience
is asking
for you to explain the intensity level
of the infectivity of the virus
yeah so i i actually i'm not like 100
sure what you mean
by that question so feel free to type
another question if i'm not
uh totally answering this but i think by
intensity level you might mean
multiplicity
of infections so how many virions are
going into individual cells
so in all of the experiments i showed
you the multiplicity of infection was
low it was on the order very i showed
it from a few different experiments very
a little bit from experiment to
experiment
it was on the order of 10 in terms of
transcriptionally active viral particles
not in terms of fully infectious virus
particles because we know that
fully infectious spiral particles are a
subset of transcriptionally active viral
particles
so that means most of the infected cells
are infected by just one varion
and maybe about 10 percent are infected
by multiple variants
uh we also grew our viral stock at low
multiplicity of infection and low
passage from reverse genetics rescue
so the variability in the viral
population is also pretty low
uh so hopefully that answers your
question by what you mean by intensity
level but if i'm not
understanding correctly what you mean by
intensity feel free to post another
question
and i can try to answer that better
great we're gonna wrap up with this
final question um are you surprised that
you saw
so few internal deletions in ifn
positive cells
yes this is another really good question
so in our inner ground positive cells
one of the types of viral defects we saw
were large internal deletions in the
polymerase but that wasn't the
most common thing that we saw and if
you've read a lot of the literature
you might know there's all this
literature on internal deletions that
interfere on induction
so why weren't we seeing more of it well
i think one factor is that we were using
this relatively pure low moi stock so it
didn't have a lot of internal deletions
but i think a bigger factor is that
until the types of experiments i was
describing
here most experiments people are doing
such as like running things out on gels
or looking perfect deletions and
segments
really only can see internal deletions
it can't see point mutations
so obviously if we were using a
technique that couldn't find any of the
point mutations we weren't doing the
single cell virus sequencing
the only thing we'd see is internal
deletions and from that
we might include that their internal
deletions are really important but
in practice they are important but we
can see that many other things are
equally if not more
thank you again dr bloom for your time
today and your important research
before we go i like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of your registration
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand for six months until
march of 2021 and lab roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's
live event until next time thank you
again dr bloom goodbye
thank you